once your exercise regimen well today I
just showed you my foot my horse ran
over my foot you know I broke my leg in
seven places since I've seen you how do
you not know that I did not know that so
I have a Cavalia horse A beautiful white
horse that was retired you know the
Cavalia show where the horses white
horses come on and I went to open the
show like as a guest you know do the
carpet and stuff a years ago like about
seven years ago and I said if ever you
have a horse that's retiring you know
could I have him buy him donate or
whatever they said well actually we do
have one coming up I went to meet her
like please can I have him please please
please and I'd written for years but I'd
often have precarious sources you know
that would like you know a little bit
dangerous and I was kind of
you know a little more self-protection
now as you get a bit older you know I
wasn't 20 anymore I was thinking I would
love one of these horses they are so
smart so I ended up with this Amazing
Horse and I would ride him twice a week
and he would live about half an hour
from here and then I was riding him last
February
I was countering him very very smart
also put him into counter from standing
still and I said to Ken wow he seems
frisky and I just had covered I hadn't
ridden him for about 10 days he'd been
ridden but I haven't he has a trainer
that you know like exercising right and
I said I'm just gonna go one more time
as you do and he bucked he reared I
stayed on and then he fell and we were
galloping
and I went over the top I damaged my
back luckily didn't break my back it was
badly damaged here and my ribs and he
jumped over the top of me so I went over
the top of him he jumped over the top of
me thankfully and then realized he'd
done wrong you know because he'd put a
buck and a rear and never done that with
me before and he just stood there I
broke my leg in seven places I heard it
break well you've probably done that
millions of times right you put you hear
that break I'd never broken anything
before
so yeah he had rods and pins yeah I had
like um is actually okay now it's like
I've got a plate there
I've got two long uh pins and three
screws here so I broke it from here down
there seven places but yesterday when I
was getting my little ponies in I don't
know why I've met your little pony yeah
see that bruise there yeah yeah one of
them ran over my foot so normally I'd go
on the treadmill just a little baby
ponies
even a little baby pony is probably 200
pounds so yeah galloped around the the
fields yeah didn't you try and ride them
when you hear them
they're miniature horses but when they
want to do something yeah they are 10
times stronger than we are and he wanted
to get out the gate which they didn't
end up running around the property with
us chasing them but he ran over my foot
so yeah I normally do the treadmill for
about an hour but probably I need a day
off do you like shopping on Amazon I do
and good news is Stevo's butt wipes for
your butt wall are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now yeah
dude